hello everyone imagine if you were just
you know chilling enjoying your day
wherever you feel comfortable for
example in a bar in a library in a park
and someone walks up to you and asks you
if you would like to see a game between
Tigran Petrosian and vasily smyslov
played in the 1959 candidates tournament
your first reaction would be probably no
I don't think I would like to see that
that's probably a really long game like
120 moves that ended in a draw but if
you're one of those people that would
say that you would miss out on a pretty
amazing game as it's not long and it's
not and it doesn't end in a draw but it
might well have ended in a draw if it
wasn't for for a lot of really in play
so this is one of the games I decided to
show between Tigran Petrosian and vasily
smyslov and Smith Slav has the white
pieces he opens with Knight to f3
we have d5 so starting off with a reti
opening c4 this is the Reta gambit and D
captures on c4 we have III Knight to f6
Bishop captures on c4 grabbing it back
at the pawn ecigs we have castles c5 and
d4 by d4 patrols and transposes into the
Queens gambit accepted we have a six
Queen to e2 this is the ejection system
b5 Bishop to b3 and Bishop to b7 now we
have at Knight to c3 and the Knight B to
d7 so this is a Smith of the own
variation of the audience system how to
how to approach it with black rook to d1
we have Bishop to d6 and now II for sin
capture son d4 Knight captures on d4 and
Queen to b8 here Smith lock already set
up a nice battery here attacking that h2
pawn we have Knight back to f3 in
defending the pawn and now b4 and here
Petrosyan has allah has not a lot but he
does have a couple of options here he
could play something like Knight to a4
which does seem like the safest move
although if you play Knight to a4
giving up d4 pawn but accepting d4 pawn
without castling first could be it could
be somewhat dangerous but there is
another option here for example there
are some tactics that you have to
calculate for example rook captures on
d6 and after Queen captures now you have
this if I move but after Knight captures
and Knight captures you would get B
captures and c3 be kept the sorry Bishop
to a4 check first and after the King
moves now B captures on c3 black would
play something like rook to d8 and now
after Knight to c4 attacking the Queen
also we have to be careful not to leave
the Queen on the dark diagonal as a3 is
coming
but even after Queen to c7 and I move
like Bishop to e3 King to g8 and
although this King is somewhat awkwardly
placed completely blocking this rook on
h8 from entering the game it is a better
position for black and it's it's
questionable if weif could use the
bishop repair and his pieces which are
not ideally placed to somewhat hindered
blacks development and take advantage of
this
probably not as Petrosyan decided not to
go for this so after before he decided
to play another interesting move he
played Knight to d5 and this isn't a
piece sacrifice as he he gets the piece
back very soon
Smith still played he captures on d5 we
have 85 now attacking the bishop and the
night so Knight captures on e5 Knight
captures on e5 and now castling of
course you don't want to capture this
night as well as then f4 pins the bishop
and black doesn't really achieve
anything here so instead of capturing
sorry instead of capturing first castles
and now Knight back to f3 as now the
knight really was attacked on e5 and
also the night now protects the h2 pawn
again we have rook to e8 attacking
petrol since Queen Queen to d3 and now a
5 with the idea of giving some
additional protection to this before
pawn and also a 4 might be an idea in
the future
so Bishop to g5 Petrosyan develops a
piece also now a fork can be met with
Bishop to c2 and after rook is developed
to c1 this bishop can even go to b1 we
have Knight to g4 and here is again a
very exciting moment in the game
Smith's love is now attacking the h 2
upon 3 times with the knight the bishop
and the Queen and the best move for
Petrosyan is playing Bishop captures on
d5 grabbing the d5 pawn but leaving the
H to pawn so after Bishop captures King
to f1 and now comes Bishop to a6 pinning
the Queen against the King but now you
have to block this Bishop to c4 and
after Bishop captures Queen captures
nice to e5 attacking the Queen and the
night if you move the Queen as missile
will gladly capture on f3 so Knight
captures Queen captures and here you
have a position where Petrosyan is
Smith's table is still up one point that
patrols and decided the sacrifice by
playing Knight to d5 and also his
position is somewhat better as this
Bishop on h2 is nicely nicely locking
the King on f1 there's already a nice
queen on on e5 and a rockin e8 this rock
is ready to jump into the game wherever
it pleases so it would be a better
position for black but Petrosyan decided
not to play this as against Smith's love
this would be easily easily losing so
instead after this Knight to g4
he played g3 defending BH to pawn but
this is actually even worse and here's
miss level will really show how you can
how you can play against the former
world champion as missiles being a
former world champion himself when he
plays a move like g3 and he tries to
keep everything in order on the board
but now Smith's level will show you as
of this moment after Petrosyan played g3
it's like Miss love is explaining to you
how how to play chess I mean it's like
he's explaining to a six-year-old how to
play chess it's also very natural and so
logical that it's it's just beautiful
here he plays a Bishop to c5 attacking
the f2
twice now so you have to defend this but
it's not that easy to defend it you
can't really block with the bishop
because III Square is covered by the
knight by the rook and by the bishop you
don't want to go rook rook to f1 if you
go rook to f1 then Bishop three six is
an idea pinning the Queen against the
rook so here he has to play rook to d2
now comes another piece attacking the f2
square Queen to a7 now three pieces are
attacking two pieces in the Queen are
attacking the f2 Square and now we don't
really have a choice here Bishop d3 is
still out of the question as now four
pieces are guarding the e3 squared so he
has to play rook to f1 and if you had
this position against Petrosyan I'm sure
you would all very gladly play Bishop
286 and you know enjoy pinning that
Queen to rook and winning the exchange
but Smith slow again very elegantly he
doesn't he doesn't rush this position he
would he really I'm sure he was really
taking his time here and enjoying
Petrosyan suffering here he doesn't go
for better 286 instead he played h6
because now you have to first decide
what to do with the bishop again we said
III is out of the question if you play
Bishop to h4 you get g5 losing a piece
so only move you have is Bishop to a4
which which pushes the bishop to a less
active square and also by playing h6 you
create some breathing room for your own
King on h7 before going into any
skirmishes so first improving the
position and only then does miss love
play Bishop to a six now pinning the
Queen against the rook here Petrosyan
moves the Queen Queen to a5 and of
course Bishop captures and f1 was played
but although Bishop captures and f1 is a
move you really want to play you know
grabbing the exchange you you have to
take a couple of things into
consideration here for example but rosin
can capture the bishop on f1 he can
decide to capture the knight on g4
but there is also one line that missile
had to calculate before he captured the
rook on f1 sorry and that is Bishop to
see to creating this knight battery here
going for the h7 square and you had to
see that if this was played that okay
for g6 then queen will capture on g4 no
harm done
but that you can actually play Bishop to
c4 and that Queen to h7 doesn't really
give you anything after Queen to h7 King
f8 Queen to h8 King ez 7 there is really
no way to continue checking the black
king and after Queen captures and g7 now
comes Bishop captures on f2 and here
comes Smith love's counter-attack King
gauge 1 and now rook to g8 and the Queen
has nowhere to go this diagonal is
completely covered g6 is covered g5 is
covered so only square for the queen is
Queen to h7 and now Bishop to e3 is
sufficient for black to win this as you
do have to exchange here probably Queen
to a5 now white could even offer a
second rook here with the idea that if
Bishop captures rook this Knight can
come to e5 and maybe continue the attack
but miss law wouldn't have to go into
any more risks he could simply capture
the bishop and after Queen captures not
like Queen e3 and now it's all over you
either have to exchange Queens and then
you lose the game is white or you can
try some more checks and after King f6
Queen d6 check King to g7 there are no
more checks and although the King did go
for a nice walk here he's back safely on
g7 and white can simply resign here
so after this Bishop captures on f1
petrosyan decided to play Queen captures
on g4 grabbing the knight also now
pinning the the g7 pawn threatening
Bishop captures on h6 against missile
had to take some things into
consideration and he decided that this
wasn't dangerous
he played Bishop to c4 he has to allow
this Bishop captures on h6 but Bishop to
c4 he really enjoys this move as if if
white ever captures on c4 he will fix
his own pawn structure the bishop is
nicely protecting the pawn on d5 and
also he's threatening to capture the
white bishop on b3 messing up White's
pawn structure
so first Petrosyan played Bishop
captures on h6 we have g6 here blocking
checkmate on g7 and now Bishop captures
uncie
or as he decided it was a lesser evil
than to allow Smithville to capture his
own Bishop on v3 and also he found he
found not-not-not
a tactic but a sea of tactics here D
captures on c4 and now he plays rook to
d7 and this is the the the real critical
moment of the game as here you can see
that although being down the exchange
he's on the attack and he does have some
pressure here the bishop is very
dangerous here Queen is very dangerous
and G for the rookies on b7 eyeing the
f7 point the knight is ready to jump
into the game so a lot of options force
missile here he could go Queen b6 you
can go Queen b8 he could go Queen to a6
and of course he could capture an f2
would check so let's see what what the
Trojans idea here was if Smith still
played Bishop captures an f2 would check
after King to g2 your queen is still
attacked you have to play Queen to c5 to
protect the bishop but now comes Queen
to f4 attacking the f7 pawn of
threatening Queen captures and then
checkmate so you'd have to here you'd
have to either play Queen to a5 blocking
this after which Peterson will capture
the Queen and then capture the bishop
leaving him with a better endgame or you
would have to play something like f5 but
then you you're completely lost after
rook to g7 check you can't go to f8
otherwise you're gonna lose the Queen
after Queen to c7 I wrote the c7 but
after king - king to h8 then comes row
captures and g4 and black is black is
lost here whatever black plays White has
a very elegant move for example ro BG 8
and now comes Bishop to f8 and it's all
over with da with the idea if you
captured the rook of course you lose the
Queen on c5 if you play rook captures
Bishop then you get Queen to h5
checkmate and lastly if you play Queen
captures an effect you get Queen to h4
check the King has nowhere to go only
move is to block with the Queen and then
comes Queen captures on h6 and this is
checkmate
so after this rook to d7 move capturing
will be a terrible blunder
so what are what are some other options
for example we said Queen to b6
is a viable option so let's try Queen b6
Queen b6 actually falls through captures
on b7 not with the idea that black is
lost here but with the idea that the
black will no longer be able to win here
what is a threatening rook to g7 again
and you have to you have to stop this if
you play rook to a7 to stop this then
simply rook captures Queen captures and
Queen captures in g6 so we'd have to
play King captures on f7 but then comes
Queen to d7 check rook to e7 blocking
and now Queen to d5 checking the king
also attacking the rook on a8 and after
rook to a6 blocking this rook to e6 you
don't want to go to the bank back rank
as then Queen captures will come with
chick so after rook to e6 now you play
Knight g5 check King moves Knight
captures Queen captures and now you
don't want to be hasty and grab that
rook and if you grab it then comes Queen
e1 check followed by Queen captures on
f2 the the real idea here how to draw
with white is actually Queen to d7 check
and now white will always be able to
check the black King White's idea is
that he wants to force the Queen out of
the out of the e-file so Queen e1 check
doesn't come with the threat of
capturing gun honey an f2 so Queen b7
check King d7 now Queenie 4 check back
again 26:27 check again and all the
other moves will also result in a draw
so lastly after rook to D 7 we said
capturing is out of the question
a Queen b6 it doesn't work what about
Queen to b8 you do have to play
something with the Queen if Queen to b8
again rook captures on b7 Angie sorry on
f7 King captures and now comes Queen
captures on c4 with check King moves
Queen captures and see if I would check
Queen d6 blocking and now Bishop checks
on g5 King a 7 and now Queen to b5 check
Queen blocks and now comes Knights the
e5 check for king the king and the Queen
black must capture rookie actress Queen
captures and here you you're still up
the exchange as black but
with white king being very safe behind
his pawns and black king being wide open
there is no way to win this game with
black so lastly we return to this
position
it wasn't just you know violently played
that Bishop captures on c4 and opened up
the D file for his rook played rook to
d7 and you can see what C of variations
missile had to calculate before finding
the right idea here is missile played
Queen to a6
and Queen to a6 is a very devious way of
stopping group captures on f7 if Brooke
captures on f7 now then after keen
captures again Queen d7 Czech rookie 7
now Queen d5 check King to v8 Knight to
e5 now comes covering the d7 and the F
7th were threatening Queen to g8
checkmate but now this was missiles idea
rook captures knight on e5 Queen
captures and Bishop back to e7 Bishop
pins the bishop on e7 threatening Queen
captures with checkmate but now comes
Queen to d6 and white White's attack is
stopped black is simply up a whole rook
and winning this game so this was
missiles idea and Petrosyan saw this
after the screen to a sex move Petrosyan
instead now he saw that rook captures
doesn't work
he played rook to c7 attacking the
bishop on c5 we have Queen 36 now
attacking the rook defending the bishop
we have Bishop to f4 attacking the Queen
and defending the rook Queen moves to to
d5 and now we have rook to do seven
again attacking smith loves Queen and
here's missile plate simply
Queen to b6 and here he forces the
exchange of Queen's Queen captures we
have rook captures and now rook to c7
attacking the bishop Bishop to b6
attacking the rook rook d7 and now c3
here's missile pushes c3 he's creating a
passed pawn we have B captures be
captures and now King to f1 allowing
this Knights to move because then the
knight couldn't really move rook to e1
was a threat now rook to the 8th comes
we had Knight to g5 attacking the rook
and here there are a lot of interesting
moves for Smith's love rook to d1 being
the obvious option but Smith's love
again really takes his time I'm sure
he's enjoying this position immensely in
place the strongest rook to f6 allowing
allowing Petrosyan a one last idea
Petrosyan plays it tonight captures an
f7 we have rook captures and now as the
rook is no longer protecting the bishop
and b6 now
Petrosyan captures it so he grabbed the
pawn now petrosyan is up upon although
being down the exchange and again there
are a lot of interesting ideas here rook
to d1 always a very nice option but
Smith slub again goes for the strongest
move and he plays rook captures on f4
and it was in this position that former
world champion Tigran Petrosian resigned
at the game what if you resign well
first of all the bishop was guarding the
queening square so by removing the
bishop you have to capture the rook as
you're gonna be down a whole rook so G
captures on f4 and now c2 and there is
no way of stopping the pawn rook
captures on g6 but check King f7 rook to
c6 blocking but now what come up to d1
check King e2 and c1 and the queen is
back in the game rook captures rook
captures and at the end of this very
nice variations miss Leveaux would be up
a hole rook with a completely winning
endgame so yeah I do hope you enjoyed it
I do hope you enjoyed this game as its
it's not very long it's actually only 39
moves but what a you know what a
complicated game and what a sea of
variation variations miss love had
calculate before before actually winning
this game against Petrosyan but you know
after Patterson played that g3 move it
was so it was so I don't know so
educational and so refreshing to see how
how smyslov punishes him so yeah that's
another game from the 1959 candidates
tournament
III didn't find any photos of Smith's of
actually playing against Petrosyan from
this tournament I don't know even
probably in those days
they didn't really didn't really
consider it important to take a lot of
photos you know there were photos there
were some photos of the players from
this tournament that were liking the top
three but not not from like every round
like like today so that's very sad but
that that is that is the case maybe
somewhere there there you know photos
exist but you know I just don't have
access to them but yeah like I said I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank James Ross Don Dugan and David
Compton for a contribution to my channel
think a lot to really appreciate it and
I don't think I will be able to do
another video today as I am making
preparations for my stream it will start
at 6:30 p.m. Central European Time I do
hope most of you can make it and I
wouldn't want any of you to be
discouraged from playing since since all
some grandmasters and international
masters applied for the tournament as
this is actually why I gave out the the
prize money so it would attract some
some stronger stronger players and it
would give you a chance to play against
them so while I'll be streaming with
Yann Almighty we will you know be
enjoying some games and I will be able
to show live some of your games when you
will be playing against these strong
players so I do I do encourage you to
apply to the tournament and give it your
best you know it's gonna it's gonna be a
blast so as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here I hope most of
you will be able to make it today thank
all for watching and I will see you soon